water has been heated and purified with
the help of solar energy a clever idea
Bolivia will come is a 29 year old
engineer he studied renewable energy at
an Italian University after returning
home he started training young people
how to install and use solar panels and
two years ago he launched an NGO called
Africa Tech Sola is aim is to promote
the use of clean energy the advantage is
that the solar energy does not pollute
the environment it is clean energy
renewable sources of energy can be used
over and over again and people don't
have to pay for electricity
because it is free a fact you don't
country becomes Africa tax Ola has
already installed solar powered street
lights and water purification plants in
his hometown but to farm lack of
electricity is a serious problem in the
region Jamaica DC in three four five
years I would like to see two aids that
the majority of Africans have this solar
kit especially in rural areas because it
is in those areas that are the most
affected by lack of electricity he's
training over 60 people from biopharm
today they are assembling a solar panel
at the local library the trainees say
they are inspired by the idea of clean
and renewable energy per acre I used to
see this kind of equipment but I didn't
know how it could be utilized a lemon or
approved eco today I'm able to install a
solar panel and assemble us all along
key function Erica and panel today now
welcome students are keen to make
renewable energy available to others and
is urgently needed in Africa only two in
five people have
to a reliable source of electricity